tensions escalated today at the border
crossing between San Diego and Tijuana
Mexico border agents reportedly fired
tear gas and promptly shut down the
crossing suppose America is like a
victim of its own marketing just keep
saying like we're number one what number
one right it's like someone who thinks
they're a ten but there are six what's
my immigration policy guys 90-day fiance
you want to come into our country
immigrant you have to marry one of our
worst people yeah you want to stay here
you got it married Darcy from
Connecticut huh that guy will be begging
to go back to Honduras and get beheaded
by a gang some immigrant to America I am
a four out of six things at Trump eights
black gay female immigrant the only
things that are gained for me is that
I'm not Muslim and my name is not Lopez
those are the only two things listen you
you need to let the people on
the caravan in because they're the ones
that control the produce and now they're
with the romaine you want to see
a real problem let them with the
avocado
we'll see how quick those borders open
right up you don't with brunch
I dare whoever is in control of that
border wall if they with his
daughter's avocados then yeah they're
gonna have a new state for the caravan
people
you